how are you Trent I was nervous man when
I got up there and looked out down
Broadway you couldn't see the end of the
mass of people I was gonna ask my hand
was shaking my hand was shaking holding
that card I was gonna ask that Trent
because the way we were situated we were
off to the side as you know I didn't
have the clear straight view shot up
Broadway from mr. state what did that
look like that mass of humanity in front
of you I've never seen anything like it
I mean I've been to Times Square for New
Year's Eve you never have that
perspective you never high enough right
you're so high on that stage that you I
mean I don't know I don't have the
vocabulary to describe it I mean it's
endless it's like an ocean of people and
you can't see to the end of Broadway it
was endless as if the people went off
into infinity it was crazy I understand
not joking I was I don't get nervous
very often my hand was sweating and the
card was shaking as I got up what was
your draft night like when you got
drafted trend so different I mean you
know they back then I was one of the
kids in New York and I'm supposed to go
on then I suppose go three and up going
six and you know you come in you have a
dinner you wake up you do the day you go
to the draft you sit in a chair like
right off to the side of the stage
there's no green room there was no
cameras but I think there was a camera
like roaming my handheld or something
and you get drafted and then you're like
done then you're on a plane to go to
your city to do a press conference I
mean it was it had one fit this is old
land I'm not 150th the sizzle as a way
that has now it's amazing what it has
turned into Trent Dilfer
tantrum so cool by the way yeah wouldn't
be a bigger fan of what it's become I
mean I just think it is truly an epic
moment for the kids you guys crush it
thanks I mean it's an NFL property and
you guys just you have the best people
talking about it and you have fun with
it and I like your song your new glasses
by the way I know your computer's
rocking and I think it's a great event
yeah I got a text from trenee likes the
beard Chris
he likes the beard
yeah we both you know we both beer
glasses combo the beer glasses combo and
then the bass shoot the bass suit the
beige suit was really nice as well Thank
You Trent I really appreciate that Trent
Dilfer here on the Richard show all
right let's start with the sixth pick of
this draft because that's the one that
people were flipping out all about and
they still are in the New York
metropolitan area what did you think of
the pick of Daniel Jones and the fit for
him with Shermer and the Giants yeah
again like most of my answers is
long-winded and complex but I like the
fit I hate where he was backed I mean
his play his potential does not justify
the sixth pick of the draft I think very
the kabocha consensus he was not overly
productive he's not overly talented he
didn't win at a high club he didn't
necessarily get the best from the least
he didn't do the things for a
Productivity standpoint to justify that
pick nor does the talent justify he's a
good athlete not an elite athlete he's a
good thrower he's not a great thrower
he's a really good leader and a great
kid so maybe not the intangible part may
fit but you know what he is I think they
got tricked by beat he's well trained
and I think that's where caught the
quarterback discussion gets sticky
around draft time is some piece um
evaluators look at training and confuse
it with talent and potential and then
some look at talent and potential and
confuse it with oh he can be trained and
there's this delicate balance of both
that you need a certain amount of juice
talent and you need a certain amount of
proof that your training is transferable
to the NFL game Daniel is a well well
well trained player with above-average
juice so it does not justify where is
picked and I'm alone I think they could
have gotten them in the teens in the 20s
and maybe in their 30s Wow
so yeah cuz gentlemen said there was no
way that he'd be there it's
tene you don't you know okay well who
was gonna take them
the Redskins weren't gonna take them
over Haskins no chance the Redskins are
doing backflips they took out Twain
asking Kevin O'Connell cokes was my
elite eleven coach that coach Duane
Haskins when he got the early eleven
here's a rich history with Dwayne asking
he's from the area like that was a
no-brainer gentlemen there's no way you
can justify saying that the Redskins
were gonna take off so who was gonna
take them did the Dolphins home over
them I doubt it
like that's just not nobody was gonna
take them yeah I mean it's it's tough to
argue with anything that you're saying
right now so now you say you'd think it
was right for Haskins to watch the
drafting of Daniel Jones as we've seen
in the video of him watching his phone
and just shake his head kind of laugh a
little bit huh we need more competitors
like that we're in this time at high
school right now where everybody's
trying to be nice all the time
being an elite competitor you need that
chip on your shoulder that is how you
respond every NFL quarterback watches
another NFL quarterback when during game
prep is like why is that guy going to
the Pro Bowl I'm better than him
that's what elite competitors think
that's how they feel that's how they
respond if anybody is making fun of
Dwayne Hoskins now he responded
they've never competed at the razor's
edge they've never felt what the tip of
the sword feels like at the highest
moment of pressure I mean that is what
we do that's maybe it's not politically
correct but that's how we respond to
those types of things that we're gonna
see assuming it all does work out
obviously for both kids twice a year
Daniel Jones versus Haskins two Giants
Redskins NFC East I mean that's a good
filet mignon steak there Trent right my
fear rich is that Daniel Jones just
became Christian Ponder Blaine Gabbert
Jake Walker why wear those that because
that draft is the greatest example of
over drafting quarter
in my lifetime and/or my time of
following the draft closely I mean those
are three quarterbacks that were
probably second third-round picks now
when I think the latest was 15 if I can
remember correctly maybe even 11 was the
latest of that group and you knew the
team was invested because they have to
try to prove themselves right so they
give these guys a pretty long leash all
not a pretty long leash on their first
team but it was pretty evident early on
that and I like all three of the guys
and I'm makes me sick that I've even
criticized them late but their careers
panned out that they would add giant
gaps in their game and they weren't
ready to play right away and I'm afraid
if he may only plays one year or if a
New York crowd calls for Eli's head and
they gotta throw Daniel in there too
soon that it'll be exposed because his
training will he get him so far and he
doesn't have the juice like a calimary
or dwayne Haskins or even a drew Locke
in Denver to carry him through those
times because that's what you need when
you don't have it figured out and I'm
the poster boy for this when you don't
have that figure out and you're just I
mean you're literally dying out there
you better have enough physicality and
toughness and grit and swag to get
through it because if you don't they're
gonna get rid of you and those three
guys I'm talking about Walker plunder
gather really nice kid great kids good
husbands good fathers good teammates
great guy maybe quite not enough juice
to carry him through those dark moments
and that's what he's gonna need and I
don't know if he has it
Trent ill hope I'm wrong I hope the kid
makes very Pro Bowls I might love being
wrong on quarterbacks sir I'm critical
eye open makes them Pro Bowls but that's
what it looks like right now yeah I'm
with you Trent Dilfer here on the Rich
Eisen show so it stands to reason what
we've been talking about with carla
marie being taken first overall good fit
with the coach and and they were
drafting with steve calm and the
cardinals after the pick to just keep
supplementing what they're building a
new
they're Trent would you agree with that
yep I did a great job I mean it's a
great fit it's a unique talent advising
like we talked about when I did your
show before the draft it buys them some
time to figure out pass protection
pulled from a talent standpoint and a
scheme standpoint because he's just he's
hard to get down
he just can be hard to bring down he'll
make plays he'll be inconsistent he'll
be wildly inconsistent for a while but
he'll have enough splash and sizzle and
Savior in him to let that leash get
longer long or longer he'll fill the
stand figures teammates excited because
nothing there's nothing and I throw guys
like more than playmates
when when Claire's our locker room see
playmakers they go okay well you can you
can mess up four or five things as long
as you can make a play and that'll buy
him time it'll buy them time I don't
think they got enough fat or rosin but
I'm sure there's a backstory to that
times not an idiot known him a long time
I'm sure they are trying to chop him
around as much they could I think what
killed them was that it came when
McShane came out and guaranteed that
Murray was going to get drafted a few
day be few days before the draft Tom
McShea DJ Bucky these guys don't come
out a hundred percent sure of anything
unless they're 100 percent sure mm-hmm
and when that happened I think it was
Tuesday if I Kember right when I saw
Todd go 99.9% this is happening I think
every general manager says well that's
coming from an owner that's not coming
from a general manager that's not coming
from a team president that's coming from
an owner and when an owner says this is
going to happen and then Todd McShane
says it's going to happen and his trade
value goes way down so that's my take on
that so they didn't get enough for Rosen
but they did a really good job and this
kid is going to be lightning in a bottle
I mean it's just that he's been about
wait and see what I remember I remember
coaching when I was like 14 as a
freshman in high school ever seen
another camp and he was I mean he was
tiny tiny but he already had electricity
and him that very few kids have ever and
he's gonna he's gonna be one of those
poster boys for the NFL
Trent Dilfer here on the Rich Eisen show
let's talk rosin what do you think of
the fit therein
I am a new coach new system again for
this kid who you've known for a long
time as well he is all groans DUP
through the way that I think he handled
everything Trent and now though you know
he's going to a team that has coveted
tool for quite some time
what are the odds that this can happen
to him again unless this is really a
good fit they're bringing in a Patriots
type system that I think suits him well
from everything that I've seen and heard
what are your thoughts on on this with
Rosen getting an opportunity in Miami
I'll just the first part second because
I don't really know that much about it I
do know about the fit the fit is perfect
and that's what I text Josh when it
happened I was just like dude great fit
believe it or not it hurts now but
you'll be thankful for this you're going
to an academic system and that's what
Josh needs is an academic approach to
football highly intellectual a lot of
burden put on the quarterback a high
level sophistication in both skiing and
training that's what will bring the most
out of Josh Rosen needs to be challenged
he needs every single day to feel like
everybody is challenging him he's at
Aaron Rodgers he's basically Aaron
Rodgers clone and how they demand
excellence from everybody and it brings
more out of them when you put that
burden on him and that's what the
Patriot Way is and that's what they're
bringing to Miami plus Caldwell who has
a track record with dealing with all
kinds of academic quarterbacks maybe the
most cerebral one of all time and Peyton
Manning so it is brilliant it's a
brilliant fit for Josh now the second
part of it I didn't know that I didn't
know that they've coveted two and you
know how I feel about to us and maybe
that changes their approach I honest I
don't have words for that because I
didn't know that was in play if that
happened to him again wow that might be
too much for anybody to handle but I
think for the time being
Josh and Willie good spot and fit I mean
Fitz is a guy that there who's going to
compete with them he's not going to
code anything is kind of full practical
jokes on them he's also going to give
them the keys to the NFL car as a
quarterback me like here's the secret
here's the stuff behind the veil here's
the stuff they're like a hundred people
though there's about a hundred 150 of us
that know the stuff that really happens
and Fitz is one of them they used to be
able to give Josh all the stuff when you
know the stuff it can speed up your
learning curve exponentially faster than
what a coach could tell you last thing
for you Trent Trent Dilfer here on the
Richards your last thing for you here
drew Locke to Denver Finley to
Cincinnati let's talk briefly about the
kids that were taken on the next couple
of rounds and where you think the best
opportunity to succeed Stidham in New
England is well obviously what do you
think the best drafted other quarterback
wound up in equality I think Locke's
did them equally great picks both I
think will be multi-year starters
because they'll have a little bit of
time to sit and learn from really good
quarterbacks one learning from the best
of all time and I've know again Jared
Stidham and I go that window way back
he's always wanted to be more Tom Brady
ish
he just always been in systems not
allowed to be tom radius so again I
think he'll thrive with the academia
part of the game to lock you know always
coveted him for a long time he sets what
they want to do I think he'll be a
really good back to the defense play
action type quarterback much like
Flakoll is so I think he'll get a year
or two of training of how to play that
type of game instead of being a spread
guy I think it'll be an action guy he's
got the traits to be a really elite
action guy we're pushing the ball you
know 15 to 40 yards down the field on a
regular basis and maximizing your arm
talent so the sending one was weird to
me because if you are trying to get if
you're trying to get rid of Andy Dalton
and drop somebody different than Andy
Dalton I think they drafted a poor
version of Andy Dalton he's got less
traits
probably a little more academic again I
keep wearing that word out but it's true
a little
a little more academic than Mandy but
less juice that one idea was not that to
me to not seem like a homerun pick I
thought there are other guys that would
bring more immediate value to try to
replace Andy Dalton and Ryan Finley but
Michael he's also got it has gotten
better every year he has gotten more
athletic every year he shows like two
years ago watch this filming like no
chance last year you're like okay now we
starting to sow some juice so he might
be one of those late bloomers all at Tom
Brady
that actually becomes a better athlete
and a higher performer when more is
expected out of it Trent you the man I
could listen to you for absolute days
and and thank you I can't wait to chat
already Thank You the man original TV
mentor morning thank you you the man
Trent you take care about it's Trent
Dilfer at dill furs dimes for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app